[Música]
se trata de un oasis en el corazón de la
provenza el parque regional de la
sangoma
desde tiempos inmemorables el hombre se
instaló en este lugar para aprovechar
sus riquezas naturales
empezando por su voz que acoge especies
raras y valiosas
[Música]
uno de los árboles excepcionales que se
puede encontrar un hueco que tiene tal
vez quinientos y mil años no se puede
saber si está completamente hueco
entonces hay algunos es una verdadera
chimenea este si miramos hacia arriba se
podría ver el cielo
aquí hasta los árboles muertos son
importantes
es materia orgánica que se degrada poco
a poco hay pájaros carpinteros que
vienen a buscar insectos que empiezan a
degradar la madera por dentro hay
pequeños champiñones hay especies de
caracoles babosas que están en actividad
de musgo degradan la madera pero toma
decenios para que se vuelva uno que le
permita al bosque renovar frío
desplomándose los árboles crean pozos de
luz que dejan espacio para los nuevos
brotes
este es el futuro del bosque
y aquí hay una pequeña regeneración que
se instalaran arces algunos estilos pero
también la esencia emblemática de la
región en la ya en 2018 la sandbox
obtuvo el sello bosque de excepción
porque además de esas especies raras el
agua es abundante aquí estos
investigadores de la universidad de
essex marsella trabajan sobre los
recursos de agua subterránea
563 y temperaturas 10 9
entonces esta agua que sale es agua
subterránea pero esta agua subterránea
hay que saber que viene del agua lluvia
que circuló en el subsuelo antes de
subir por aquí la cnte bomb tiene en la
baja provincia calcárea el rol de
castillo de agua esa en donde el agua
lluvia se infiltra es almacenada y sale
poco a poco en las fuentes tal como aquí
en la fuente de ven y en las otras
fuentes que se encuentran en los otros
pequeños valles
más abajo el agua de este río construyó
lindas pilas y pequeñas represas
es una estructura geológica que lleva
dos nombres toba y travertino en la
práctica es lo mismo es piedra caliza
que se deposita usando todos los objetos
que se encuentran en la naturaleza en el
retornado del agua entonces puede ser un
pedazo de madera tal como este con el
tiempo se incrusta de piedra caliza
gracias a esta agua el macizo de las
ambón es el más exuberante de la región
ocho cursos de agua no recorren entre
ellos varios de manera subterránea
cada año los investigadores acompañados
por alumnos de sexto grado del colegio
lincoln probance exploran las entrañas
de las antón
si encuentren una piedra linda en el
suelo le pertenece a la cueva todo lo
que está en la cueva le pertenece no
podemos tomar ni dejar nada no se deja
ningún rastro
nos dirigimos al corazón del macizo
nueva ruta del reguerón una cavidad
acuática
en el terreno los alumnos descubren el
trabajo de los científicos y usan
incluso los datos recolectados por sus
ondas
[Música]
recuerdan que me de esto
con todos estos datos los alumnos logran
recrear el funcionamiento del ciclo del
agua en el medio de la piedra caliza y
trabajar durante la clase de biología
historia o geografía sobre las nociones
que son el recurso del agua el recurso
de agua pero también los riesgos
relacionados con las inundaciones y de
aprendizaje funciona
no tengo una memoria especialmente
escrita entonces ver esto me ayuda a
estar en el terreno porque se entiende
mejor la piedra caliza está en el agua y
pasará del estado disuelto como el
azúcar o la sal al estado sólido
[Aplausos]
todo en el fondo de la cavidad
últimos instantes de la clase en la sala
de las arenas en el suelo de arcilla
depositada por el agua
sin piedra caliza no habría cueva y sin
agua tampoco es la simbiosis entre el
agua y la piedra caliza que hace estas
cuevas y el resto es espectacular es
lindo es magnífico es el agua y la
piedra caliza es lo que se descubre bajo
tierra
de todavía mata
[Música]
cada año los investigadores llevan al
terreno a cerca de 12 grupos de la
región
una iniciativa original que permite
sensibilizar a las jóvenes generaciones
sobre la conservación de las ambos y en
general la protección de la naturaleza